[Music]
john's in california hey john how are
you
i'm better than i deserve dave how are
you sir just the same sir how can dr
john and i help
well i want to give you guys advice um
i'm trying to have
help my mom make a good choice about a
move
um she's had a little history of
codependence with me and she lives in
oregon
she wants to move down here to
california but i think it's too
expensive for her to do that and i'm
just curious
john dave how i can walk her through the
baby steps and explain to her
maybe what might be the best choice for
her right now at her age
how old is she she's 70
and she's divorced and when i was 13 my
parents went through a pretty horrific
foreclosure and
lost everything in that process so
there's a lot of history there too with
this
do you have grandkids does she do you
have kids running around that she wants
to to see or she want to see you
i'm being more serious with my
girlfriend and i think she sees that in
the forecast
for sure but not right now i'm currently
a bachelor i'm in baby step 3b
36 self-employed here in l.a
so yeah and dave you can hop in i'm
going to recommend you don't try to
solve this as a math problem
there's a math component to this but you
may be dealing with
a 70 year old lonely mom who recognizes
that she's 70 and wants to be around her
baby boy
she may be feeling that um there's some
other woman that's going to replace her
and so she wants to make sure she can
get down there and get wedged between
the two of you where she rightfully
should be
um and i'm just kidding by the way
this sounds like a really emotional
conversation that again
sitting down with a with a calculator
isn't going to convict her heart
um i would want to sit down and want to
know what she wants to do and why she
wants to do it
but she can't afford the property she
can't afford a property obviously that's
part of the conversation but
i'd honor her um and just my lonely mom
wants to be around me in her last
10 15 20 years yeah so uh she has no
money is that what you're saying
well actually dave it's fascinating she
took a she took a horrific fall a few
years ago and there was a settlement
last year
of 72 000 she put into our money market
account
she also has no debt she's got no car
payment so i've been again trying to
walk her through the baby steps i'm on
3b right now personally
and um she's got 138 000 in her money
market
you know so i'd love to see her use that
to buy a condo
but as we know that won't get you
anything in southern california i mean
there's
some options for her for condos in
oregon maybe arizona or nevada but
um like you said john it's both it's a
math thing but
but also it's so emotional because when
we lost the home it was just
my mom and i lived in a hotel for a
while we were on so i think it's
she's kind of in shell shock that she
actually has money to do something with
it now
yeah and sometimes that makes the 72 000
feel like it's 720 000 for her
and so uh it's it feels like it's a lot
of money and
you and i know it's not especially if
you're talking about buying something in
california so
um i i you know i think you talk work
through the heart
side and let's just admit where we are
and then let's look at the reality of
the math and math says mom
you're going to be one state over that's
probably what the math says
but you don't start with that as the
opening salvo in this discussion
um and uh so
and you don't bring her over there where
you are supporting her
but just because she wouldn't make a
decision to live within her means
and and demanded to be had it was
entitled to be
close to you because that's not true and
so
you know you you have to be kind and
loving and put her in a position where
she's self-sustaining and that's gives
her dignity
and then from there you can work out
travel or whatever needs to be done to
maintain the connectivity
i've got a little bit of of what i would
consider unpopular
belief on the kids side of this
conversation
and i don't like to think of it as an
obligation dave or a rule
but i do find people in my generation
their 30s and 40s
who don't feel like they have a
responsibility
i don't even like that word because it
makes it sound like mowing the lawn but
i think we should reach out to our
parents and i think we should love our
parents and i think we should
spend intentional time trying to connect
with them and i think that i need to
build into my life space where i'm with
them either physically or
if we can't do it where we're connecting
um and i know that turns into when
you've got to move into the basement and
there's all kinds of it turns into a a
job right to a
like a reliability a rhythm of travel
between
la and in oregon and oregon you know i
mean because it's not that big a jump
yeah or or nevada but you're you know
the responsibility wasn't what you were
saying where you were so
responsible for paying the bills to pay
their bills no
no but but i do i do hear this talk of
my parents my mom just wants to come see
me
and i want to say yeah because that's
your mom and she loves you
and if you have hardened your heart to a
place where you just don't want to be
around them you don't want to see them
man you got to look in the mirror on
that one because that's your mom that's
your dad
and of course everyone's got their
histories that they got to deal with but
i just want to see people my age and
this clearly isn't this guy i
i love john here he's trying to to solve
this problem both
in a heart place and a math problem but
i want to see all of us
lean more towards respecting our folks
trying to honor our folks and trying to
be in connection with them in some shape
form or fashion we've got to
reconnect with our lineage in those ways
i think a lot of people
have trouble delineating the
the emotional responsibility for
connectivity versus financial
responsibility for caretaking that's
right it's like if i do one i got to do
the other
and it's easy to get taken advantage of
yeah oh they're taller than me they're
taking me hey can i 500
right now and i get the short leave
mom's mom's a travel agent for guilt
trips you know and so
that's right like you know i was the one
changing your diaper you
ought to give me some money you know and
so um that kind of stuff it's more
if more young people were like john who
sees his mom and loves her wants to
honor her and also sees the
the coming cash flow train wreck that's
on the way
and it wants to reach a really healthy
place what a gift yeah
very cool